this is weird and don't answer this
question if you don't want your mutter
but I have to know why you brought this
up but I didn't hear you discuss you had
an extraordinary disagreement with your
wife about yourself do you know what I'm
talking about
by myself you mean yes with interest
one night as you do we were talking
about stuff and of course being
circumcised I said she said she said
you're not circumcised I said what do
you mean you've only known me a few
all my life I remember my mother telling
me why because it was fashionable at the
time she said you're not circumcised I
said that's ridiculous I should know if
I'm sorry no conversation but the next
day I happen to be seeing my doctor my
doctor for my annual physical of course
so while he was down there
oh by the way disagreement I am
circumcised all right because she says
I'm not and he goes
[Laughter]
[Applause]
so he looked down again and he said hey
I'm Jewish I know the difference
you're gonna have to change your
facebook status to the more beasts you
[Applause]
you